اذا كان مديرك ممن يضغطون عليك للعمل لي
ساعات طويله حاول ان تجد طريقه لايصال هذه
المعلومات لهم هناك دراسه تشارك فيها 33
شركه ومؤسسه في امريكا وايرلندا واستراليا
لتجربه نظام العمل باربعه ايام في الاسبوع
بدلا من خمسه والنتائج حتى الان مذهله
الدراسه تشمل 969 موظفا على مدى 10 اشهر
حيث تم تخفيض عدد ساعات عملهم بمعدل ست
ساعات اسبوعيا من دون تغيير الاجور
بالنسبه للموظفين النتائج غير مفاجاه
97% يريدون الاستمرار في نظام الاربعه
ايام ويقولون انهم لاحظوا انخفاض ضغوط
العمل والارهاق والقلق وبعد في يواجهون
مشاكل اقل في النوم لكن المفاجاه في
النتائج بالنسبه للشركات وهذا ما يجب ان
تخبره لمديره النتائج ان الشركات حققت
زياده في الارداتي بنسبه 8% خلال فتره
التجربه وبالنسبه 38% على ثانوي كما
ارتفعت انتاجيه الموظفين بشكل ملحوض
بالاضافه الى انخفاض التغيب من معدل 0.6
يوم في الشهر الى 0.4 كما تراجعت ايضا
معدلات استقاله موظفين الجهاد المشاركه في
الدراسه اعطت نظام الاربعه ايام تقريبا
ايجابيا بمعدل 7.7 نقاط من اصل 10 والاهم
وانها كلها بلا استثناء قررت عدم العوده
الى نظام الخمسه ايام لكن اذا كنت من
ارباب العمل انتبه لبعض التفاصيل فبعد
التجارب قال الموظفون انهم سيطالبون
بزياده كبيره للرواتب اذا طلبت منهم
شركاتهم العوده الى الخمسه ايام وانت كم
يوم تعملوا في الاسبوع وما هو النظام
المثالي برايه شاركنا برايك مع منشن
لمديرك في التعليقات